for more on what's going on in europe
let's bring in chris livesay in rome
where i was just a few days ago and
chris the heat was unbearable at times
good morning nate yeah check this out
i'm at the tiber river in rome i should
not be able to stand here right now
there's a drought now worse than decades
that's brought the water level at least
five feet lower than normal it means i
should have water covering my feet
perhaps up to my knees but this is just
the tip of the iceberg compared to the
heat wave that is hammering europe and
it's forecast to swelter on
unprecedented heat from london to athens
firefighters in greece race against the
flames to help an elderly woman escape
from her home before fire descends from
above when the fire out runs the
firefighters it's up to local residents
a few buckets and whatever water they
can carry but water is in dangerously
short supply around italy's biggest
river the po wants fertile fields for
producing risotto rice wine and pasta
are now brittle patches of mud water is
so scarce this barge has been revealed
for the first time since it was sunk in
world war ii and in rome long submerged
ancient ruins dating back to emperors
hadrian and nero now poke above the
surface
the ancient romans used the tiber river
to navigate to supply the city and to
build it it simply wouldn't exist
without this river but today thanks to
the worst drought in 70 years parts of
it have been reduced to a stagnant swamp
around the country towns have been
evacuated due to wildfires with nine
cities on a heatwave alert the
government blames climate change
in central spain forests are ablaze the
smoke and flames forcing thousands to
flee many hiding in a sports arena like
68 year old fernando jimenez
[Music]
trees nothing i don't know
now the drought and the heat are
devastating farmland creating a perfect
storm for the global food crisis that's
already been made worse by the war in
ukraine that's blocking millions of tons
of grain in the black sea all of this is
jeopardizing the lives of millions of
people in the developing world gail
chris lipsey and rome a perfect storm of
mess it sounds like